try them out while show the Super Bowl
features racially segregated national
anthems this is being done to end racism
supposedly but it only causes and
encourages what it pretends to be
fighting against also the UFO invasion
is finally underway it's an exciting
time for alien enthusiasts like myself
though some are speculating that perhaps
there is another explanation for the
sudden epidemic of mysterious aircraft
in our skies we'll review all the
possibilities today plus the worst
ecological disaster in American history
is currently unfolding in Ohio but you
probably haven't heard much of anything
about it why is that we'll talk about
all that and much more today the Matt
Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you find yourself saying you can rely on
the government well of course you don't
say that the time to start planning for
your retirement is now the US blew
through 31.4 trillion dollar uh debts
debt ceiling in December and still the
White House refuses to reduce spending
with that amount of money you could buy
homes for almost everyone in the United
States uh our economy is in trouble it's
time to start thinking about your
Investments and your future you need to
consider diversifying into gold with
Birch gold Birch gold is a leading
dealer of physical precious metals in
the U.S their Dynamic team of former
wealth managers financial advisors and
commodity Brokers can help you diversify
your portfolio into gold and silver
they'll even show you how to convert
your IRA or 401K into IRA and precious
metals text Walls to 989898 to claim
your free info kit on gold and then talk
to one of their precious metal
Specialists with your retirement at
stake you want to be confident in the
financial services companies that you
work with including who you choose for
purchasing physical precious metals text
Walsh to 989898 and protect your savings
with gold today
well it has finally happened the Alien
Invasion has begun now I know that some
of you have been engaging in absurd and
unsubstantiated conspiracy theories
coming up with ridiculous speculations
about how the unidentified crafts being
shot down in our airspace are somehow
not space aliens from a distant Galaxy
but I for one will not demean myself or
insult your intelligence or my own with
any wild conjectures like that we must
assume that they are space aliens until
proven otherwise that's the most
reasonable thing to do right now and uh
if it's not the most reasonable then it
is at least the most fun all I know is
that I have waited my whole life for
this moment and I'm not going to let
anyone take it away from me now
would also like to State for the record
at the top in case our Intergalactic
visitors are listening to podcasts as
they hover in our skies and plan their
invasion
that I have been a big supporter of
aliens for a long time you can check my
social media feeds aliens and my podcast
catalog to confirm this I understand
that you guys will want to incinerate
much of the human race that's totally
reasonable frankly I would do the same
if I was in your position but you should
also know that some of us down here have
been very pro-alien and and it would be
it would not be fair to lump us all
together I'm not throwing anyone under
the bus here
I'm certainly not trying to betray my
own species I wouldn't do that I'm just
saying that if you want a list of human
beings who have been especially
disrespectful to you I'd be happy to
provide it for your reference two names
that could go right on that list by the
way work here at the daily wire Ben
Shapiro Michael Knowles very anti-alien
in fact I hate to say it but every host
here at the daily wire has been
viciously anti-alien except for me I
want anyone get hurt okay I don't want
that
but if people are going to get hurt you
should hurt them first that's all I'm
trying to say but before we discuss the
UFO invasion in any more detail I want
to begin the show with something that is
a far greater priority to most Americans
that would be of course the Super Bowl
indeed I have I have no doubt that if
the aliens had actually landed and
emerged from their spaceships last night
for all we know they did because if the
whole event was captured live on camera
it still would not have even trended on
Twitter because most Americans would
care more about the game and this is the
hardest pill for me to swallow as an
alien Enthusiast that all the Sci-Fi
films got it wrong because they all
assumed that however the Alien Invasion
plays out it would at least be like a
really big deal that's what all the
Sci-Fi writers and films they all just
assume that at least maybe we get
enslaved and killed by aliens maybe we
fight them and be but no matter what
happens
everyone agreed that it would like
everyone would care at least that there
are aliens here but that's not how it
actually has played out you know they
didn't take into account the Sci-Fi
writers our terminally distracted and
frivolous culture that can't pay
attention to anything or care about
anything for more than 18 minutes at a
time in reality aliens could come here
and actually begin leveling our cities
and enslaving Mankind and we would get
bored with the story in less than a week
because as long as we still have
electricity and fast food and the
internet and our streaming services I'm
not sure the average modern Western
person would really care whether
Intergalactic Space Invaders Congress or
not
In fairness to those people on the other
hand space alien leadership couldn't
possibly be worse than our current
leadership and there are a lot of
reasons to think it'd probably be better
so maybe they would have a point there
with all that said
there was one moment during the Super
Bowl broadcast that uh is it's maybe not
more important than aliens but it is
worth reflecting on uh even in light of
our impending planetary Doom a moment
that would probably be very confusing
for our extra solar visitors if they
happen to turn on the game uh the NFL
continued last night its alleged efforts
to fight racism in the United States
efforts that for the past several
seasons up to and including the game
last night has included writing the
phrase end racism in huge letters
directly on the field
and many people expected that this would
be enough
we imagine that all the people of the
world would see the phrase end racism
Written In The End Zone and they would
all say wow the NFL is right we should
end racism and then racism would be
ended and Global Peace and Harmony would
commence after all racism only exists in
the world because no one has ever
suggested that it shouldn't exist
so we simply needed the NFL to go hey
what if we cut out that racism stuff and
everyone would respond oh so we
shouldn't be racist jeez okay well we
hadn't thought of that and that would be
it
at least that's what we thought but
somehow this strategy has proven
insufficient and so it has added uh the
NFL has added another prong to their
anti-racist battle plan and yet again
last night the Super Bowl began with the
performance of two national anthems
there's the regular national anthem the
one written by Francis Scott Key after
he watched British ships lay Siege to
Fort McHenry in Baltimore during the the
War of 1812 and then the so-called black
national anthem called lift every voice
and sing
this was the third year in a row where
the most watched sporting event of the
Year featured a special national anthem
for one special racial group
it's the third time the broadcast has
featured the song yet it's the first
time that the song was performed on the
field uh which is significant because
that's of course how they also perform
the real national anthem
now all of this is of course totally
grotesque and outrageous and the kind of
gratuitous display that no country
outside of the western world would ever
be stupid enough to allow
and yes I use the word allow here
intentionally you'll notice that nowhere
else do they permit individual racial
groups to come up with their own
national anthems that are then performed
before major events
that's the sort of thing that can only
happen here
and I don't mean that as a compliment
now there are as always some people
looking to defend the indefensible and
minimize even the most outrageous
excesses of leftism they're even
conservatives who enjoy participating in
this past time there are many
conservatives who love doing this and
from those people who who you know we've
heard that well the lift every voice and
sing
it's a nice gospel song It's not
actually a national anthem uh so there's
no reason for us to object to it they
didn't call it the black national anthem
during the broadcast after all they
didn't specifically say that during the
broadcast
for example a guy named Ross Shuman who
identifies himself as a conservative
made this case to me last night he
tweeted
um quote at no point in time was lift
every voice and sing called a national
anthem on the broadcast why do you take
the left's bait
well except that the NAACP has billed
the song as the black national anthem
since 1917. not to mention the woman who
performed the song at the game Cheryl
Lee Ralph said that she was performing
the black national anthem that's what
she said
she posted quote it is no coincidence
that I'll be singing the black national
anthem lift every voice and sing at the
Super Bowl on the same date it was first
publicly performed 123 years ago a happy
Black History Month
so everyone including the performer
herself
knows what the song is
and why it's being performed
there's a reason they had her sing it on
the field with the audience in the
stadium standing in solemn reverence
just as they do for the real national
anthem there's a reason why every media
report has hailed the inspirational
rendition of the quote black national
anthem and they've all called it that
specifically
the media the NFL the left
they're not celebrating the performance
of a gospel hymn okay their intention is
not to glorify God that's not what
they're excited about that may be the
focus of the lyrics in the song
but that's not why it's included in a
broadcast and that's not the intention
behind its performance
the intention is to do the only thing a
racialized national anthem can do which
is to divide Americans along racial
lines Elevate some races above others
you know some races are special and they
get two national anthems while the rest
of us have to settle for just one while
diminishing our most cherished National
traditions
because the message of the black
national anthem is that the actual
national anthem isn't enough it isn't
good enough it isn't inclusive enough
like nobody disagrees
that black people should have a national
anthem known as no one is saying that oh
there's no no one is no one is looking
at black people and say you don't get a
national anthem this isn't for you
now the point is that the national
anthem is everyone's national anthem so
if you're a black person that's a
national anthem if you're a white person
that's your national anthem
if you're a Native American that's your
national anthem it's everyone's national
anthem
but the other message the other idea
behind this which is just as false and
just as Insidious is that uh the
situation this is what they're trying to
claim this is why they're doing it
that the situation hasn't improved much
for black people since the song was
declared the black national anthem over
100 years ago it was a rallying cry
during the Civil Rights battle well
bringing it back now not just bringing
it back but elevating it to a status
equal to or even surpassing the real
national anthem is meant to send a
message that black people still do not
have their rights that the Civil Rights
Battle of a hundred years ago is still
ongoing
which is all total nonsense
and we see yet again that those
supposedly fighting Against Racism are
in fact determined to create racial
divides deep in them where they already
existed open new wounds and reopen old
ones and keep the resentments of the
past Forever at the Forefront of our
minds
the whole point of performing
the national anthem the real national
anthem is to first of all show our
respect and gratitude for this country
and for the traditions in our country
and for the people who have you know
made all this possible for us it's also
to show our unity and to celebrate our
Nash our national identity
under one flag and one God
that's the point
but the powers that be don't share that
goal their goal is exactly the opposite
and that's what the black national
anthem is really all about
now let's get to our headlines
I hate to break it to you but uh you
will die someday whether you're a
first-time parent early in your career
or a recently empty nester you need to
make sure that you have a plan in place
for when you meet your demise which is
coming around the corner at any moment a
will is not just about your stuff it's
about uh it's not just for the elderly
either when you leave behind a will you
leave behind a legacy you ensure that
your wishes are honored when you're
unable to see them through you ensure
that your loved ones are taken care of
even after you're gone my partners at
Epic will will help you decide today how
the future will look if you die tomorrow
did you know that 50 of Americans don't
even have a will don't be just another
statistic for just 119 in as little as
five minutes epic will could help you
create your last will and testament your
living will and even Healthcare power of
attorney their step-by-step online form
makes it incredibly easy all you got to
do is fill in the blanks go to
epicwell.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Walsh
now let's talk about UFOs
um I have to tell you this has been an
exciting weekend for me but also a
painful one in many ways exciting
because of the alien invasion very
exciting uh but painful because I have
to confront this deep Rift in my own
family this division between us
uh between those of us in in my family
who care about UFOs and those who don't
and sadly I am apparently alone on my
side of the rift because I've been
trying to talk to my wife all weekend
about the UFO story and give her updates
but all she does is like laugh at me
last night I was I was telling her about
the latest and and as I'm speaking to
her she pulls out her phone and starts
texting her sister a transcript of what
I am saying to her in the moment while
laughing at me
and I'm saying can you can you take this
seriously for five seconds I mean what
is going on why are you not focusing on
this and then I even tried to tell my
son about this he's a nine-year-old boy
and um I figure if anyone is excited
about aliens as excited me to be a
nine-year-old boy so I told him about I
told him you know I was talking about
the cylindrical UFOs that we'll get to
in a second uh that they shot down and
that had no visible means of propulsion
and he said what does visible means of
propulsion I said well it means that we
don't know how they're staying in the
sky
okay we don't we can't tell
and then he looks at me and says wow
cool can I go play outside now
oh you want to play outside in an alien
invasion
go ahead sorry that I'm boring you
so it's been tough at home but uh the
news cycle has been great anyway here's
a daily wire report that I think gets us
up to speed pretty well
it says new UFO sightings appear to be
popping up all around the United States
over the past few days in the week since
the US military shot down a suspected
Chinese spy balloon off the coast of
South Carolina officials say at least
three other strange flying objects have
been blasted out of the sky and there
have been multiple additional incidents
leading to Temporary restrictions in
pockets of sky around the Midwest so the
most recent development a U.S F-16
fighter jet shot down a UFO over Lake uh
here on on Sunday according to the
officials the defense department said in
a statement that President Joe Biden
ordered the strike on the recommendation
of military leadership after an Airborne
object to fly out approximately 20 000
feet
um was in U.S air space over the lake a
location chosen for its low impact on
people below and the improved odds for
debris recovery
the dod statement said the object was
detected Sunday morning and its altitude
raised concerns including that it could
be a hazard to civilian Aviation the
object flew in proximity to sensitive
DOD sites and had potential surveillance
capabilities but likely no kinetic
military threat
uh continuing along says these objects
were much smaller than the balloon shot
down over the Atlantic Ocean last
weekend uh it's according to
um Chuck Schumer
says he said that he he thinks that they
that they are balloons that's his theory
about it Pentagon spokesman Brigadier
General Patrick Ryder said on Friday the
UFO shot down over Alaska was about the
size of a small car
and not similar in size or shape to the
suspected Chinese surveillance balloon
so
there was this the balloon that they
were very hesitant to shoot down and in
fact they let it float over the entire
continental United States before they
finally shot it down they're they're you
know very hesitant to do it and they
decided that we can afford to wait for
like days and days and days while it
goes over the entire country and uh and
over military installations and nuclear
sites and all the rest of it
so they said we could wait for that
but now all of a sudden if they see
anything in in the sky that they don't
immediately recognize they're just
taking it out
so there has apparently been this shift
in strategy that's interesting
here's a CNN reporter talking about
um the reports we've heard back from the
pilots who have gone up to investigate
and engage with these objects and here's
what they are saying
this is kind of unusual that these
Pilots saw different things and that is
sort of I guess adding to the mystery of
all this yeah not even the pilots
apparently were really able to identify
what they saw and just to take you back
for a sec on Thursday the uh the U.S
defense officials sent F-35 fighter jets
up to try to figure out what this object
was that was flying around near Alaska
those Pilots we have learned have given
very conflicting accounts of what they
actually experienced with some pilot
saying that the object interfered with
the plane sensors other Pilots saying
that they didn't really experience that
other Pilots saying that when they
looked at the object they could identify
no identifiable identifiable propulsion
system and they did not know how it was
actually staying in the air cruising at
that altitude of about 40 000 feet so
this is all added to the pentagon's
wariness of describing in more detail
what this object actually is until they
can get more information through the
debris that they are recovering right
now
so that's something again to keep in
mind that they are they're claiming that
they don't know what these things are
and they don't even know how they're in
the sky they don't know how they are
managing to remain Aloft in the sky and
yet they're just shooting them all down
anyway that's what they're claiming
that's the story they're telling us
and the the theme that emerges rather
quickly here is that the story they're
telling us makes no sense at all because
you don't just shoot things down without
having any idea what they are especially
when again we saw the previous week how
cautious they apparently were to shoot
something out even when they know what
it is I mean they knew it was a balloon
from China that was here to on a
surveillance Mission the Spy balloon
and even knowing that they were cautious
about shooting it down
now we're supposed to believe that they
have no clue what these are and they're
like oh let's just take it down I'll
figure it out later let's shoot it down
and uh well you know if we will collect
the pieces and figure out what it was
I find that hard to believe but don't
worry we have our best uh men on this
job and women including Karen Jean pair
who here she is explaining how the U.S
is handling all this
why is why is the American Military
shooting something out of the sky over
Canada because it's part of uh NORAD
there is a the NORAD is part of like a
part of uh it's a it's a what you call a
coalition
exactly and so that's why we were able
to do that again we didn't do it on our
own we did it in in
clearly in in in step with uh Canadia
what did she say Canadia she did
it's uh you know it's we shot it down
it's uh NORAD it's part of the uh it's
you know NORAD is uh it's the thing with
the uh it's there's a it's a it's a you
know it's a it's a thing with the group
it's a it's exactly right it's and
they're in Canadia uh it's the it's the
country right it's up there
these if if there are space aliens
coming to invade us this is who they are
I I don't think it's coincidence like we
get a we get a a
dementia patient in the White House
who then proceeds to hire a bunch of
dementia patients and that's when the
aliens show up I don't think that's a
coincidence they're waiting for their
moment and they looked at each other and
said this is it this is our time like
there's not going to be a better time
they just this guy okay and now they're
here
um
but here are the clips that really
matter
um I want to play two sound bites this
is from General Glenn van hurk of the
U.S Air Force
first of all here he is in the press
conference we already heard a little bit
about this but here he is talking about
the objects and how they don't know how
the objects are remaining in the sky
I am not able to categorize how they
stay aloft it could be a gaseous type of
uh
balloon inside a structure or it could
be some type of a propulsion system but
clearly they're uh they're able to stay
aloft I would be hesitant to and urge
you not to attribute it to any specific
country we don't know that's why it's so
critical to get our hands on these so
that we can further assess and analyze
what they are
okay now but here's the Big Clip because
he's he's asked directly if these are
space aliens and at least we can all
matter how you feel about all this
maybe we can appreciate the fact that
it's not often in a press conference
with a military General that you get
direct questions about a potential Space
Alien Invasion this might be the first
time I don't know I'd have to check but
I maybe is this the first time in
history that this has been asked in a
this directly and explicitly and
here's what he says
hi thanks Pat and thanks for doing this
this is for General van hurk uh because
you still haven't been able to tell us
what these things are that we are
shooting out of the sky uh that raises
the question
um have you ruled out aliens or
extraterrestrial terrestrials and if so
why because that is what everyone is
asking us right now
hey thanks for the question Helena I'll
let the Intel community and the
counterintelligence community figure
that out I haven't ruled out anything at
this point we continue to assess every
threat or Potential Threat unknown that
approaches North America uh with an
attempt to identify it
haven't ruled it out so there it is what
else do you need to know but don't be
alarms
because the good news is that if you've
seen the movie myself as a student uh
you know as something of a of a an
expert in this field of alien research
part of my research is watching all the
alien movies and I've seen them all
and one thing I learned from uh the
movie Signs from Mennonite Shyamalan is
that uh the aliens they they could come
all this way light years away they
figure out how to travel across space
and time traveling at the speed of light
or even exceeding the speed of light
they make it all the way here and then
their plot is easily foiled by a locked
basement door and a glass of water so
um if that was an accurate reflection of
the alien knack for strategy and
planning then I think we'll be okay
but
look
I know that some of you are skeptical
that these are space aliens and you
might point out that it's quite a
coincidence that we had the whole
Chinese balloon news cycle and then it
immediately leads to this now what
exactly the connection is between those
two things
I don't know but it's interesting that
these two news Cycles have happened back
to back uh you might also point out that
if an advanced race of intelligent
beings have mastered Interstellar travel
and they are at least slightly more
intelligent uh and better at strategy
and planning than the ones in the M9
Chamberlain film then they probably
couldn't be taken down that easily by a
few missiles that we launch at it
you know I and I understand those
arguments fair enough so let's just for
the sake of argument allow ourselves for
a moment to entertain the possibility
that these aren't aliens not saying I
believe that but let's entertain the
possibility
if they aren't it's still a it's still
to say the least a very bizarre
uh event
because you know I know the most popular
theory on social media right now from
from what I've seen anyway anecdotally
at least among right Wingers in
particular is that well this is just
this is like a giant distraction
mechanism this is a diversion right the
bite Administration they're they're
pointing at the shiny objects in the sky
and saying look at that because they
don't want us looking over here at
whatever else they're doing
I I have to say I I do find that theory
a little bit underwhelming
um I don't find it very persuasive
and it's not because I don't think that
they wouldn't use diversions and
distractions no no they do that all the
time don't get me wrong the media the
buy Administration uh the elites they
are constantly doing that they're
constantly distracting Us by saying look
over there the shiny object what because
they don't want us looking over here so
I so that part yeah absolutely but
that's exactly the point they do it all
the time and easily they don't need to
come up with some elaborate UFO hoax to
distract us
um they we are the most easily
distracted
group of people to have ever walked the
face of the Earth as I said at the top
we can't we can't focus on anything for
more than 15 minutes even if there
actually was an alien invasion nobody
would focus on it for that long
um it doesn't take it takes almost no
effort to distract us
and so usually the by Administration in
particular if they want to distract us
then they'll you know they just wave a
pride flag or something or light the
light the White House up in Pride colors
and uh and then they can you know just
some some virtue some real simple easy
virtue signaling thing so they could say
look we're standing up for gay rights
and meanwhile
you know we're not we're not looking
over in the other direction they don't
want us to look so that's all it usually
takes
um it would not require anything close
to this kind of elaborate planning that
would go into
a hoax of this kind if that's what this
is
um
the other thing is that
they obviously don't want us to know
exactly what's happening
they know more than they're telling us
but yet they're telling us something
which is also an interesting detail
because they didn't need to tell us
anything it would be pretty easy to not
tell us about any of this and we
wouldn't know
um it's it's not like most of us are you
know these are from what I understand
for the most part these are not objects
that people saw
and then we started talking about it and
then they came along and said oh yeah
we're trying to figure out what that is
it's more like they told us hey there
are these objects in the sky well what
are the objects I don't know who knows
but they're there
so it's something that's happening that
they want us to know about but they
don't want us to know exactly what it is
how do you make sense of all this I
don't know exactly
but I do know that however you explain
it I'm certainly incompetence has to
play a role here
and that also makes it more difficult to
speculate and more difficult to come up
with reasonable theories because there's
always that element of of incompetence
that you have to factor in
like I said a moment ago I mean just the
simple fact that they're claiming they
don't know what it is and yet they're
shooting them out of the sky
I don't know what it is they're also
claiming that they know it's not a
threat
um they're claiming to know that don't
know what it is not a threat yet we're
shooting it down without figuring out
anything else
none of that makes sense
could be an indication that they're
hiding something well they certainly are
hiding some things maybe that's part of
what they're hiding
but also just keep in mind that these
are in you just heard Karen Jean pair
she represents the White House and she
represents it well or at least I should
say accurately
so these are incredibly incompetent
idiots and you you always have to
remember that
so it is actually plausible it's
plausible
that they really don't know what these
things are and they're just shooting
them down anyway
um and and partly they're doing that
because they got embarrassed by the Spy
balloon before
all of this adds up to like we talk
about on the show a lot just the total
collapse of public Trust
which rears its ugly head constantly and
this is another one of those cases
um because all we can really know is
that whatever is happening they aren't
telling us the truth about it whatever
they say is happening it's probably not
that
whatever else it is who knows
and that complicates matters too because
well if it's if we're if we're following
the rule which I think is usually a
pretty good rule that whatever they're
saying it is it's probably not that
well they they have themselves publicly
entertain the notion that it might be
aliens they've also come out and said
it's probably just balloons
so if we're going with the it's not what
they say rule then it rules out both the
most extraordinary explanation between
space Island and then the least
extraordinary which will be balloons
because from the powers that be we've
been we've been given both of those
possibilities
which leaves
a lot of room in between
um
all right
I have to mention this story as well and
this is one you know if you're going
with the this is all a distraction thing
then uh well there is at least one major
story happening in the country right now
that they would want to distract us from
although again I still say they don't
need any alien or UFO hoax to
successfully distract us from this story
especially because most people aren't
paying attention to it in the first
place even though they should be
um
and it's another story where things
don't add up and it's just it's it's the
official narrative doesn't make a lot of
sense
uh and we're obviously not being told
everything but we'll try to piece this
together if we can we'll start with this
from uh the guardian
five days after a train carrying vinyl
chloride derailed and exploded near the
Ohio Pennsylvania border Crews ignited a
controlled burn of toxic chemicals to
prevent a much more dangerous explosion
thousands in East Palestine pretty sure
it's pronounced Palestine not Palestine
that's how it's above a town of about
five thousand people evacuated and
officials warned the control that the
controlled burn would create a false
Gene and hydrogen chloride plume across
the region phosgene is a highly toxic
gas that can cause vomiting and
breathing trouble and what you use was
used as a weapon in the first World War
though no one died in the accident the
catastrophe serves as a wake-up call to
the potential for a more deadly Freight
uh Freight rail derailments Public
Health Advocates warn by one estimate 25
million Americans live in an oil trained
Blast Zone and had the derailment
occurred just a few miles east it would
be burning in downtown Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh with tens of thousands of
residents in immediate Danger
um
so
yeah this train derailment
lots of toxic chemicals on the train
and this happened uh when this happened
something about a week ago
toxic chemicals on the train
and then there's an explosion in a fire
and it's releasing all these chemicals
into the air and also into the
groundwater
and we're told that the burn was
intentional that they're doing a
controlled burn of toxic chemicals a few
miles from a populated area
and there's more going on here they
actually they they to make things
stranger they actually arrested a
reporter who was reporting on the
situation this is from wsws in a
shocking incident Wednesday police
arrested a national news reporter in the
middle of a news conference by the Ohio
governor on the train derailment in East
Palestine following the February 3rd
crash uh government and railroad
officials had authorized a controlled
release quote unquote of thousands of
pounds of toxins into the air and
groundwater the reporter Evan Lambert of
news nation was at the back of the
elementary school gymnasium in East
Palestine covering completing a live
broadcast as the governor was about to
speak he was approached by local police
officers and someone with the National
Guard who told him he was talking too
loudly Harris reportedly told Lambert to
stop the broadcast Lambert ended the
broadcast and then there was a verbal
Exchange
um according to reports at one point
Harris pushed Lambert the video posted
by NBC station WKYC shows police
surrounding Lambert at the back of the
gymnasium Lambert's engaged in animated
conversation with Harrison officers but
does not appear to be doing anything
resembling disorderly conduct he soon
escorted out by police and then forced
to the ground for no apparent reason and
handcuffed
so this is another one where they told
us initially that he was reported for
being uh for being belligerent or or you
know physically assaulting
turns out that's not what happened
so the burning toxic chemicals
intentionally they're arresting
reporters
meanwhile people's pets are dying left
and right this is the New York Post
animals are falling sick and dying near
the site of a hellish Ohio train
derailment last Friday which released
toxic chemicals into the air according
to reports sparking fears of the
potential Health impacts the crash could
have on humans
Taylor Holzer owner of a dairy farm just
outside the evacuations on East
Palestine said that several foxes he
keeps on his property have become
mortally ill
he said others have developed watery
eyes and puffy faces have
uncharacteristically refused to eat for
several days and then there are other
um
people in the area that have also
reported that their animals are falling
sick and it's not just pets either
one of the the most disturbing aspects
of this and I think we have
this report or that uh
fish there are you know the rivers and
water sources all around and there are
fish that are turning up dead in the
rivers uh and this is miles and miles
from the site of the crash I think we
have one of those reports here
at the area well and groundwater are
safe however after this couple saw dead
fish in this Creek that you're looking
at they're deciding to not take any
chances
oh there was hundreds Russell Murphy is
referring to the fish now Belly Up in
Leslie run he and his wife noticed them
last night barely 48 hours after the
fiery derailment five miles away this
was huge huge environmental effects
that's now one of many concerns the EPA
now faces the impact of the fish yes
there was a impact to those however the
levels as we have seen it are protective
to groundwater we are aware there are
some wells along that for residential
Wells environmental cleanup Crews were
at and actually in that water today so
are these booms which are used to catch
and stop anything that shouldn't be
flowing here or into water wells which
Murphy uses for just about everything
uh so the fish are turning up dead pets
are dying uh toxic chemicals in the air
in the groundwater and yet they tell so
there's nothing to be concerned about
it's uh it's for some reason it's not
it's not it's not dangerous to your
health as a human being uh it's not
getting into the water supply people are
drinking they're claiming even though
the fish are all dying
um if you're if you're curious what this
all look like by the way here's a report
from uh now this and only reason I'm
really playing this is just to see some
of the footage if you are watching video
podcast so you see some of the footage
of what this looked like while all the
chemicals are burning let's watch this
for a minute you're looking at a toxic
tale of harmful and potentially deadly
chemicals purposely being burned off by
authorities but why let's rewind this
all started with a train derailment in
East Palestine Ohio a town of nearly 5
000 people five of the cars that
derailed were carrying Vinyl chloride a
dangerous chemical linked to multiple
cancers it's used to make a whole bunch
of things from car parts to PVC piping
but on its own Vinyl chloride can cause
blisters headaches dizziness and can be
deadly if breathed in for too long it's
also unstable and at least one of the
train cars was at risk of exploding and
sending deadly shrapnel flying as far as
a mile and while that massive explosion
didn't end up happening many are
wondering if the way authorities are
going about mitigating the incident is
the best course of action to avoid a
catastrophic explosion officials
conducted a controlled release of vinyl
chloride a few days after the derailment
they pierced the train cars so the vinyl
chloride could drain into a trench and
burn it resulted in this authorities
said that the controlled burn would
release hydrogen chloride and phosgene
into the air yes as in World War one
chemical weapon phosgene so what does
that mean for residents well everyone
living within at least a two mile radius
of the derailment site was ordered to
evacuate ahead of the controlled burn
authorities released an evacuation by
map and essentially said if you're in
this area leave or risk dying because of
toxic fumes authorities have been
monitoring the air and water quality
since the controlled release started and
said that none of the readings were
concerning but many evacuated residents
still have questions namely when they'll
be able to return home safely while the
possibility for a massive explosion is
no longer in danger there's been no
timeline given for when it will be safe
for people to return to the affected
area
uh by the way I've I have if you if you
notice we're sort of piecing together
local news reports and you know things
from Twitter uh
that you know as I'm talking about this
and that's because that's where I'm
learning about Moses Twitter uh give
Tick Tock a hard time but in this case
there are residents in the area and
other people that have been following
this that have been reporting on it and
we have to rely on that because for the
most part the corporate media has had
very little interest in this story
if you go to cnn.com or NBC News one of
those New York Times
um
you're not going to find much of
anything about this
even though again to review
trade derailment they intentionally burn
toxic chemicals sending them into the
air in the water supply uh pets are
dying fish are dying uh people are
likely getting cancer as we speak okay
all that is happening
and there's very little interest in it
this is
I mean easily already one of at least
one of the worst ecological disasters in
American history already it's that
and that's based on what little we know
because again in spite of the fact this
is happening in the modern United States
okay this is not happening in the middle
of North Korea somewhere where they've
closed off all the The Avenues of
information this is happening right it's
happening in Ohio
and um yet we're being told very little
about it and from what I've heard from
people in the area what we are being
told makes it seem a lot better than it
actually is it's even worse than what
little we're being told about it
so this
easily one of the worst ecological
disasters in American history could
proved to be the worst
kind of an American Chernobyl in many
ways
and just like with Chernobyl or many of
the similar kinds of uh disasters we're
not even going to know the the full
impact of this if people are getting
cancer right now we're not going to know
that they're not we're not going to know
the full impact of it for years down the
line
and we might never know
so this is something that we should be
keeping track of a story to keep track
of
um
and it's also worth noting I think that
you know
I I can't help but notice
that this is yet another major
transportation related disaster
that's happening not just under the bite
Administration but happening with Pete
bootage as our transportation secretary
so
people to judge was given the job of
Transportation secretary because he's
gay and for no other reason is no
relevant experience the only reason he
got the job and everybody knows this
only because he got the job is because
he's gay okay he likes to have he likes
to have sex with men and so for some
reason that qualified him to be
Transportation secretary and what have
we seen since he took over we've seen uh
historic disruptions in the supply chain
we've seen chaos at our ports we've seen
unprecedented historic events like the
all flights across the country being
grounded
and now we have
one of the worst trained derailments
leading to potentially the worst
ecological disaster in American history
this is all under this guy's watch
on top of everything else I think we
could say that this is
this will prove to be the most
disastrous diversity hire ever and I'm
not sure there's there's been a worse
one
but again this is a story that we should
keep track of
all right much less important news uh on
a lighter note going back to the Super
Bowl before we get to the comment
section and you know people have been
talking about the commercials talking
about and again it's one of the things
people talk about for like half a day or
less but there was finally a trailer for
The Fifth Indiana Jones movie and people
are
because Disney's doing a fifth one
people are somehow excited about this
film let's watch the trailer
[Music]
my memory is a little fuzzy
are you still a Nazi
[Music]
from him
doing here
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I don't I don't know how people
they people just never learn you know I
I it's this is part of the programming I
guess
and that we are a culture obsessed with
entertainment and um
and when it comes to part of the reason
why we like to be entertained all the
time is because people all in fact
people say this I could turn my brain
off I just want to watch something where
I can turn my brain off
yeah well do you ever turn it back on is
is the question
so somehow people never learn because
I'm watching some of the reaction to
that uh trailer and most people
including like people that I know are
conservatives seem pretty hyped about it
they're pretty excited oh it looks Rose
good this is gonna be great
and I'm just wondering in no offense but
how stupid do you have to be at this
point to actually be excited for a
franchise Reboot film from Disney
like how many times do you need to see
how this works before you learn that it
is always going to be terrible
like it it and the only way to stop it
is if people just stop showing interest
in the films and stop going to watch
them
because what's going to happen is this
is this stupid movie is going to come
out and people are going to flock to the
theater it's going to make a billion
dollars and 90 of those people are going
to leave the theater saying that was
terrible it was woke garbage
it was woke garbage that I just gave my
money to and the next time they put out
more woke garbage you know another
franchise but I'll go watch that one too
and I'll keep watching them and keep
giving them my money until they they've
until it changes
I will I will reward this with my money
and I will keep rewarding it until
magically they stop doing it
I don't know about that plan
look Harrison Ford is a million years
old
um and then they've got this actress
Phoebe Waller Bridge who was a Bridger
or whatever her name is
who's going to be uh she's in the film
and they're setting her up as the new
Indiana Jones
because remember in Indiana Jones four
they had Shia LaBeouf and now we're
pretending he I think he was wasn't he
uh Indiana Jones's son in that film and
but now we're pretending he doesn't
exist so I was getting rid of him
uh and they're largely doing that
because well they don't want the new
Indiana Jones who they set up to be a
man at least of all a white man so now
the new one has to be a woman so they're
going to set up the the new female
Indiana Jones
she'll be taking the reins or the whip
in this case so it's going to be a
geriatric Indiana Jones teaming up with
a girl Indiana Jones
and what is the appeal of that exactly
and I can guarantee you that the entire
film it's going to be nothing but a
whole bunch of jokes about how Indiana
Jones is this bumbling idiot man who
can't do anything right and so he needs
the uh the the the smart alec woman
there who can kick ass and get things
done
you know just like your guarantee it's
gonna be the scene where Indiana Jones
is about to be taken out by the bad guy
and then he hears the The Gunshot and he
he thinks that he got shot he looks over
and it's the girl standing there save
the day and she'll make some you know
wise crack you know that's gonna be the
whole movie
and people will still go it'll still
make a billion dollars and people will
still watch it even though we all know
what it's going to be
just let these things die okay let them
die
on that note let's get to our comment
section daily cancellation
[Applause]
[Music]
Maxine says when I was in high school I
fell to this social contagion mainly
from the internet not in school I was
100 certain that I was a boy I wanted my
breasts removed I wanted to take
testosterone so I could have a deep
voice five years later I shudder in fear
thinking about what would have happened
if I went through with it thank God I
found people like you to wake me up
before I ruined my life
um
well I'm happy to hear that you were you
were saved from that you were able to
turn away from that uh before getting
entirely sucked into it I'm happy to
hear that I was able to play some some
kind of role in that
on the other hand I am terrified to hear
uh you tell me this story and then tell
me five years later so you're looking
back on it five years ago so what that
tells me is that five years ago
it was already that bad now it doesn't
surprise me and I'm aware of that but I
think it will be surprising to a lot of
people that even five years ago so I
think many people think of this as like
the last year or two and it's gotten
really bad with the with the Trans
social contagion but uh even five years
ago
it was it was already you know uh it was
already very much
a Contagion
Whitney says Dwayne Wade's kid is the
only case I've ever heard where the
father is pushing the kids transition
and the mother is fighting it
is the mother fighting it
because Gabrielle Union is the mother
right or or no maybe you're right
because the Gabrielle Union I think is
the Stepmom of the kid and
so I'm not sure I don't remember all the
details of the story but what I do know
is that yes whether whether he's doing
it above the the uh protests of the bomb
or not
this is a case where the father is very
clearly
a playing a central role in pushing the
transgenderism on the kid
um and it's it is unusual like you just
you don't usually see the fathers doing
that It's Not Unusual to have
transgenders and pushed on kids as we
just talk about this happening all over
the place
but in almost every case that you can
think of
certainly in all the prominent cases
that get a lot of attention uh it's
almost always the mom pushing this on
kids
just like as I've made this comparison
many times to Munchausen by proxy
because that's exactly what this is
Munchausen by proxy that's been you know
a phenomenon that's been known about for
a long time and it's almost always a
woman in that case like historically
it's almost always been a woman and with
Munchausen it's a it's almost always a
mother who is
pretending that her child is sick in
order to get attention so that she can
get attention or in the worst cases she
is making the child sick so that again
she can get attention and that is
precisely what is happening here you are
making your child sick
um psychologically sick emotionally sick
and also physically sick when you start
putting the poisons in and the hormones
and everything puberty lockers and
you're doing it so that you can get
attention
Nathan Smith says man I was really
hoping Matt would show the hitting the
brakes makes you slow down Dr Hamada
clip I laughed so loud when that bit
happened it's like something from a
freaking sitcom there are some real
morons in this local government here in
Tennessee yes I forgot about that moment
so let's let's relive that now I forgot
until I saw your comment that was a good
and I got a laugh for me sitting in the
room in the hearing room this is the
last clip we'll play from this Committee
hearing which has proven quite fruitful
in terms of uh clips and show content so
this is the guy again who tried to
Corner me on my credentials and we know
how that went for him he did the same
thing to an actual Doctor Who played
that clip Dr Hamada this is another
moment from that questioning of the
doctor that I had forgotten about until
now but I did enjoy it in the moment
here it is
amazingly liberal Europe has
let me just say the United States has
com has severely exceeded even what
liberal Europe has done on many uh
facets whether it's gender
transformation or the issues of life or
the issues of euthanasia Etc
I don't know what the problem is but it
seems like here in the United States we
are rushing to extreme positions and
with regards to this in particular the
UK Sweden and Finland have actually put
the brakes on with regards to these
gender transitions in our pediatric
population
you good all right representative
Clemens you recognize
yes thank you Mr chairman I I got to
take issue with your position about
these European countries I think what
you just said about finland's actually
completely false
well you just said that they put the
brakes on this entirely
is that accurate are you going to sit
here and testify to this committee that
Finland just put the brakes on this care
entirely
from what I understand they have slowed
down they have not they have they were
fast tracking things like this but from
what I understand they have
now they've now they're slowing down
they hadn't put the brakes on it
putting brakes on slows you down
it was just man it was great there were
so many moments like that it was just uh
this guy
uh Clemens I forget his name now Lee
Clemons I think he so many attempts it
wasn't just me just so many attempts to
back people into corners and to get a
get like a gotcha moment and it kept
backfiring on him over and over again
and I love that because it's not even
semantics either it's like
um yeah they are they are putting the
brakes on but as you know to play the
analogy out when you're in your car and
you put the brakes on it doesn't mean
that you are screeching to all that
might be how this guy drives
legislator but uh that's not how it's
supposed to go it just slows down and it
also is by the way completely true that
um in a lot of these European countries
they are putting the brakes on
slash slowing down with a lot of this
stuff
um
and that should tell you something
because usually
you know when you look at Europe
Western Europe in particular you can
find that they're you know they're
always like a few train cars ahead of us
on the crazy train and so you can look
at where they are and you know where
we'll be in the future but in some areas
they are pulling back at least ever so
not maybe not completely
but they are pulling back from some of
this because they've seen how disastrous
it's been while we just go Full Speed
Ahead so that is what's happening
another great moment there
to celebrate President's Day this year
the daily wire is launching our
president's
our presidents for sale sales what it's
called with 40 off new annual
memberships we are giving you 40 get
access to the world of daily wire plus
with Fearless documentaries gripping
movies Dennis prager's the master's
program and the entire library of Jordan
Peterson's work including uh new
productions like Exodus logos and
literary and Aunt literacy and on
marriage coming down the pipeline to a
TV or laptop near you we have new
episodes of Ben Shapiro's the search
Exodus part two are much anticipated DW
uh kids content and Pendragon later this
year to sweeten the deal like ice cream
we're also giving you up to 40 off
select items in the daily wire shop take
advantage of our president's for sale
sale today uh you know that he would so
just go to dailywire.com subscribe to
become a member today that's
dailywire.com subscribe now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
our first daily cancellation of the week
revisits a theme that we have become
familiar with in this segment another
video has gone viral of a young person
appears to be gen Z bitterly lamenting
the fact that he's expected to work in
fact he says that this expectation is
sick and twisted quote unquote
here he is
it's sick and twisted that I have to
work just to survive just to live my
life for basic ass Necessities like I
don't want to work until the day I die
just to eat and sleep basic human
Necessities it shouldn't be
controversial
Free Housing free health care shouldn't
be a pipe dream and I know a lot of
people are going to be like oh you
should be doing this or that no like
what if I don't want to be rich what if
I want to achieve
I still have to work till the day I die
just to live just to survive people give
up their entire lives
just to retire at the ripe age of 60
whatever
for what to get paid dirt even then
people destroy their bodies physically
and mentally
just to feed into a capitalistic system
that does not give it about you God
didn't make me the smartest Angel but I
know that needs to change
and I want to be told that I'm
ungrateful that
I should be happy to have a job where
it's taking up 40 hours of my week
you know I want to spend time with my
family I want to do that is fulfilling
to me but all that like requires so much
privilege it requires so much wealth and
it's just
messed up
40 hours of my week people are complain
about a 40 hourly job they blow my mind
you know how you know how lucky you are
I know he said I don't I don't really
told that I should be grateful well you
should be grateful you brat you know how
lucky you are if you only work 40 hours
that's it only 40 hours a week that's
all the that's that's all the time
you're working think about that the
amount of work period that you do in a
week is only 40 hours
um that is incredible to me I can't even
like conceive of only doing 40 hours of
work in a week okay so we have again
a young man who appears to be well fed
appears to be living in some kind of
comfortable shelter presumably a house
or an apartment and who is obviously
blessed with any number of luxuries like
a phone internet connection we can
assume copious amounts of hair product
he has all of this and yet doesn't
believe that work should be a
requirement to maintain it it's sick and
twisted that he should have to work just
to live let alone to afford his hair
conditioner now
as I've often said in response to these
kinds of disturbingly common complaints
from his generation about the fact that
you have to work is like
about the fact that you have to breathe
you might as well make a video whining
like you're telling me I have to breathe
every second of the day just to live
exhale inhale exhale inhale all the time
just to live what if I don't want to
breathe what if I want to live at the
bottom of the ocean like a starfish why
should breathing be a requirement this
is sick and twisted
found a certain way you'd be you'd be
kind of right it is unfortunate that we
have to breathe we have to eat we have
to sleep all of these are chores that we
are compelled to complete every day or
in some cases every second of the day
it'd be a lot easier if we didn't have
to do any of that it'd be easier if we
could exist as Immortal indestructible
Supermen who need nothing and want
nothing and can do anything without
expending any any energy at all that
would be nice
but that is not how things are or will
ever be
you can complain about it but those
complaints in 20 cents still won't even
buy you a bottle of water especially
with inflation now our friend with the
hair says that working should not be a
necessity
he says that there should be a universal
housing Universal Health Care we should
be given all the food that we need to
eat
all right so who exactly
is building the houses that we are
living in who is cultivating the food
who's providing the medical care you
could say well the government will do it
but the government is not a genie that
can make things materialize out of thin
air the government can only hire or more
likely conscript other people to build
the homes and harvest the food and so on
what this means is I'm constantly having
to remind the younger generation and my
own generation is that no matter what
happens
no matter what system is in place
someone lots of people have to work in
order to keep all of society afloat and
all of the many mouths including your
own fed
people have to work there is no way
around it our system doesn't demand it
capitalism doesn't demand it life
demands it what you are demanding is not
that you get to drop out of the system
but that you be granted the privilege of
benefiting from it without contributing
to it you want others to work for you in
exchange for you doing nothing
you want slaves is what you want that's
what you want you have all the moral
credibility of a plantation owner in the
1840s you have less moral credibility in
fact because even those plantation
owners personally did more work than
what you're willing to do apparently
so you want to do literally nothing
and have everyone else do everything
but what you can't explain either
morally or economically or logistically
is why any of the rest of us should
submit to that system why should we
agree to that
you know you're sitting there saying hey
I have a proposal um here it is I'll do
nothing at all and you guys will take
care of me and do all the work and in
exchange I will contribute absolutely
nothing of value to the world so you'll
keep me alive and comfortable and you'll
do everything for me and I will do
absolutely nothing to help you or to
make your life any better how's that
sound
well it sounds like the easiest deal in
the world to turn down
it sounds like you're a parasite and you
should be thrown out onto the street and
you should be forced to contribute to
your own Survival or die that's what
should happen
that should happen like this kid not
even a kid a grown adult
today
he should be thrown out I'm assuming you
probably these parents probably take
care of them throw them out on the
street and say you're done you this is
for your own good
figure out how to survive
that's what it sounds like that's what
you need sounds like life needs to give
you some shock therapy son sounds like
there are a whole lot of people in your
generation who need the umbilical cords
finally cut
it sounds like you've been living with
nothing at stake no skin in the game no
real pressure and you need some pressure
you need some consequences introduced
into your cozy pointless existence
by the way just so you know
the only reason you're able to exist and
survive is such a soft non-contributing
little brat is because of capitalism you
complain that capitalism has made your
life so difficult but in fact perhaps
the greatest indictment on capitalism is
that it has made your life far too easy
capitalism's greatest flaw
is you okay the greatest problem with
capitalism is it has made people like
you possible because prior to our modern
capitalistic age somebody with your
attitude would be dead you would have
died a long time ago if you refuse to
work every day and I mean every day all
day sun up to sundown that's the
situation that most people historically
have faced and even today in most parts
of the world you are working every day
every single day sun up to sundown and
when the Sun goes down you fall asleep
dead tired and then you get up and you
do it all over again and if you tried to
drop out of that system or if you
complained that it was it was too sick
and twisted and you didn't want to
participate in it you either would have
died of starvation
or else the other people in your
community or Village would have banded
together and killed you
or perhaps if you're lucky they merely
would have banished you to the
Wilderness where you could die of
exposure or starvation or get mulled to
death
that would have been your fate in
literally any society except for the one
you're complaining about
a guy like this complaining about
capitalism it's like a billionaire on a
private jet complaining about fossil
fuels and the fact that those two would
agree on nearly every issue is not a
coincidence
the fact that the anti-capitalist Gen Z
tick tocker lines up ideologically with
the billionaire class
is not a coincidence but that's
something to explore another day
instead I'd like to wrap things up with
it with it with a different thought you
know we've talked about Mr hair and uh
you know and and why he cannot have what
he wants
um he cannot he cannot have the sort of
existence that he feels entitled to
but let's let's not allow that to
distract us from a more important point
he can't have what he wants
and also
he shouldn't want what he wants
as a young man you shouldn't want to not
work you shouldn't want to Coast through
life
he says he doesn't want to achieve
anything and in that lack of ambition
and that mentality he is joined
unfortunately by many in his generation
but it is a deeply depraved mentality it
is not natural it is not normal or at
least it shouldn't be
as a young man you should have big
dreams and goals you should have designs
on like Conquering the world you you may
lack wisdom and experience but you
should not lack for ambition I mean
that's the one thing you should not lack
for
that's the one thing you should have in
abundance
it's what generations of young men
before you had even if they had nothing
else they had that
I can remember being in my early 20s I
was impulsive somewhat petulant some
would say I still am on both counts but
I had ambition if someone had offered to
hand me a million dollars when I was
like 22. no I would have taken it
because I'm not crazy but I didn't I
didn't want it to be handed to me I
didn't sit around dreaming of that it
wasn't my dream was not winning the
lottery or earning an inheritance from a
rich relative that I didn't know about I
wanted to earn it myself I wanted to do
it myself so that I could say that I did
it I wanted to scratch and Claw my way
to success
if anything my biggest flaw was that I
turned down help even when I needed it
because I wasn't willing to admit that I
needed it
because I wanted to climb the mountain
myself or fail by myself many young
people through history have been driven
this way it's not when I say this about
myself I'm so special I'm not that's the
point it's totally normal or at least it
should be
to have this insatiable desire to make
something of yourself as a young man is
supposed to be the most normal thing in
the world and that's why
I just look with with revulsion at the
young people who don't have this
ambition the Folly of Youth is supposed
to be an over abundance of ambition you
know fearlessness a propensity to to
take too many risks
to be too wild in the risks that you
take in pursuit of greatness
we're supposed to be giving you lectures
about being patient and taking things
one step at a time and not trying to
conquer the world overnight
even at my still somewhat maybe arguably
somewhat young age of 36 especially now
with six kids I am supposed to be the
conservative and cautious one and I'm
supposed to be saying to guys like Mr
Hare hey settle down be careful be safe
don't overdo it okay you don't have to
conquer the world overnight
instead it's exactly the reverse even
now even now me middle aged and and with
a family of eight to support I am still
far more willing to take risks far more
ambitious and vigorous in pursuit of my
goals than these gen Z Tick Tock whiners
who are younger and have nothing to lose
like you you if you that's why I've
always sang if you're a young person you
have no family no kids nothing
you can go out and do anything nothing
should be stopping you or holding you
back you can move anywhere you can try
you can try different things you can
take risks there's almost nothing at
stake even if it goes horribly wrong you
end up homeless or something it's not
the worst thing in the world you don't
have any kids you could use scratch and
Claw and you find you you live in a car
for a while lots of people have done
that
it's not ideal but you can do it
now is the time to do it where's your
energy where's your desire for greatness
how can you be this jaded and lazy
already
well I know the answer
and it's not that the world is so much
harder for young people today I don't
want to hear that yeah it's it's not
that they've been dealt a tougher hand
than anyone else in history who's ever
dealt now there are some unique and
profound challenges that young people
today face of course but every
generation has their challenges you
don't have to go back that far in
history to find Generations who face
struggles that none of us could ever
conceive of that's how hard they were
so that's not it I think the answer is
much more banal the fact is that the
digital age phones screens porn video
games social media has acted as a great
mental numbing agent kids aren't
programmed from a young age to seek
stimulation and affirmation uh from
anything but
the little dopamine machines that they
carry around in their pockets the only
success they crave is the kind that can
be measured in likes and shares they're
never alone with their own thoughts long
enough to develop a sort of Rich inner
life where all of those dreams and
Ambitions are supposed to live and grow
now there may be more to the problem but
there isn't much more to it than that I
don't think there is
we got an entire generation addicted to
phones practically from birth and as a
result we destroyed for many of them any
hope that they that they might become
successful
and well-rounded
as people
and along with that we destroyed
civilization as well but the good news
is
that
um
the aliens are just going to vaporize us
anyway so it's all a moot point
in the meantime however Mr Hare is
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
shows move over to members block hope to
see you there and uh if you want to
become a member you can do do that using
Code Walsh at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]